hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today I want to do something a little
bit different there's a young
entrepreneur been fallen recently on
YouTube her name is Michelle Phan she
has a great channel that serves as an
inspiration for a lot of young women
most of her channel deals with makeup
now i'm not into makeup but her message
is awesome she teaches women to believe
in themselves to have confidence to know
that the life that they want is out
there and they can achieve it and they
can accomplish it and she shares her own
story in a really personal way and it's
something that is really inspiring and
motivating and what I wanted to do is
ask Michelle a question today so
Michelle I do a lot of work helping
entrepreneurs and a question that comes
up often is about building a YouTube
channel building a brand you've
obviously had a huge amount of success
in doing it and I wanted to ask you one
question your number one tip for
entrepreneurs who are trying to build a
brand on YouTube what would it be what
would you recommend that they do I love
to hear from you if you can make a
youtube video reply that would make my
week I love to see that I know you like
making things look really pretty and
fancy it can be raw it doesn't matter to
me just want to get an answer or if you
could leave a comment below that also be
be awesome for those of you who don't
know Michelle go check out her channel
it's really amazing and Michelle keep up
the great work inspiring young women
you're doing a great thing and hope to
hear from you soon